okay just a few words of of introduction
welcome everybody on this beautiful day
first lecture of the season everybody is
just on the edge its students have just
had the first date with their teacher
right so it's like complicated it should
be the beginning of an adventure but
it's really like the first episode of a
reality show right with all of that
complication so if you see that kind of
strange look in the audience it's that
sort of post date post first date
feeling also first aid here for you
right and I hope you will come back hope
that we will be nice for you julian has
offers JDS of architects as an office
based in Copenhagen since 2006 year
maybe for other partners is it right or
for pinus 05 team of five before that
was plot with be aki angles which was
exactly five year experiment study in
2001 before that or may rotterdam for
just a little bit a little bit of time
before that was finishing the last of
six schools Bartlett I think was the one
that killed you all have you could argue
that if you do six schools of
architecture and one of them actually
you graduate there's something wrong
with that school all right so somehow
that school tricked you into becoming a
regular student and getting a degree
that was the Bartlett but before that
was also already at oma so at oma
rotterdam again as a student so some
kind of illegitimate transfer backwards
and forwards between school and an
office at the moment you're actually out
of school you get out of the office like
really fast and set up your own off
and it goes like this so it's a kind of
nomadic story so before that first
standard oma is about another five
schools which gets us back to Brussels
and before that I think you were born in
Brussels right so sort of super Brussels
but operating in Copenhagen and I think
what's of course grade is is that your
office and you yourself have been
embarrassingly successful and so there
is this kind of phenomenon of that
moment in time even it becomes somehow
almost kind of Scandinavian phenomenon
or at least this this part of Europe in
which a series of architects are asked
and can deliver architecture which has a
certain very sharp clear edge to it and
it's 10 it seems to me what's what's
kind of common about this work is that
there's never anything the same it's
like really relentlessly every time
different so it's a kind of requires an
almost military capacity to generate for
each different job a completely
different concept but also for that
concept to be in a way super sharply
defined so that in a certain sense the
project speaks for itself that's the
theory of it this goes everywhere from
kind of lamppost two staircases to
cities so if you are used to thinking of
objects like furniture having having to
having a having kind of self branding
capacity in with this generation of
architects that's also true of cities
and everything in between so I think
it's a sort of a super interesting
phenomenon which you know of course
because of the exhibitions because of
the books because of the videos because
of the blogs and so on so the last thing
you need is actually to listen to the
acting all right because this work is
speaking for itself and also speaking
through multiple medium but we did the
old-fashioned thing to invite the
architect to come and talk to Julian
great that you're here
okay get the lights out okay so thanks
mark for this intro and 4 i'm writing of
course things been for dealing with all
my little issues to get here and lucia
as well so i'm going to show first I'm
just going to show the office because I
kind of like my office and like the
people in it and like this at this
aspect of the office which is very much
you know compliant to my own sort of
pass is mark described which is the sort
of a multi-faceted international
location where you can see a lot of
young people obviously some older ones
but I'm not claiming to employ sessile
bellman is working with us on some
projects and this is our new office in
Brussels rather empty still this is a
happy french guy delivering a project
you can see some New Yorkers in the
background another thing that's obvious
is that because we work in these sort of
multi-national kind of conditions we are
also working you know using sort of the
kind of basic media's of today and this
is a meeting we had with Michael speaks
who I was teaching for in Kentucky but
also was working with on our book agenda
this past year this is just a normal day
at the office we're Italians rest
and so that's kind of the image of the
our practice in a way the flag of it
which should be flickering and you know
changing because of course being a young
office we have a lot of incoming and
outgoing and this is an image of the
places where we've been working and
where we've been sort of developing
projects sometimes failure sometimes
successes I'm just going to show some of
the successes quickly without going into
details a psychiatric hospital in a in
close to Copenhagen in an editing error
a project that's called the VM houses
I'm not going to go into details because
I'm sure you know all these projects so
I'm just going to ask me sure one aspect
of each for this one the fact that we
develop these sort of weird balconies
that were meant to actually activate you
know a potential vertical park and what
came out of it was this we have
condition of overpopulation of bbqs onto
the balconies meaning that it is active
in in the sense of crazy view from the
photographer the M house and then the
mountain the mountain is a very special
project that now all this project will
develop this plot and what's special
about this one what I think is
particularly specially this sort of void
in between you know the housing in the
parking why why I think this is special
is because that's the place where
actually a performative take is
happening obvious the sort of
performance of the unknown is happening
where you have basically this kind of
staircase that kind of takes you up and
it's publicly accessible and takes you
all around the building you know all the
way to the peak up there which is also
the Mount Everest picture you might have
heard another thing that was interesting
about this building is that then sort of
party organisers starting started taking
it over and taking it into a sort of
playground for their own happening so
there was this distortion festival
electronic music festival happening in
the
the mountain which is a pretty sort of
unexpected event for us when they asked
us to to do this is happening also under
the river where this guy's an umbrella
Vegas actually covered so I'm going to
go through a series of like three
typology of performative architecture
one is performative installation and
starting actually with two projects in
New York one in 2006 we did in an artist
place I guess most of you know the the
small gallery we were given a tiny space
inside the gallery to sort of do
whatever we want it and the idea was
instead of like showing you know an
actual series of project or
installations or sort of a dacoit models
of our work we decided to actually make
a sort of an exploration of on space
like trying to let people discover space
and maybe that's the kind of compression
and extension of space so the way we did
it is actually to set up a program that
allows to receive the entire new york
city block through this through this
visual installation which i'm going to
show hopefully is going to work so what
you have is what you should have
so I'm just going to explain this is the
space this tiny space is in fact a half
space of the existing gallery so what we
did we build this wall and then we made
a retro projection over onto it and we
have as you can see up there little
camera that's a sensor and it senses the
location of the guy of the person in the
space you can be multiple people in the
space and the point of it is that as the
person works towards the screen it will
actually walks towards the entire new
york city block all the way to the
street behind and so it looks a little
bit like this the first space that you
will encounter is actually the storage
space of a outer space so it's a rather
messy space we had to kind of record no
visually the whole series of spaces
behind as he goes through this we will
have sort of a studio another studio
that goes then into an apartment of the
artist and beyond that there's a sort of
rooftop and then you can see the other
side of the street so this is what like
one sort of compressed series of spaces
put together into you know a sort of
experience that makes you go beyond the
space that you within and this came up
as a kind of idea to actually explore
you know the condition of space or the
perception of space itself which is
something that we don't get to do much
in architecture when we deal with you
know build projects like we do another
installation was one that we did for the
contemplating the void exhibition for
for Guggenheim where we decided to if I
just showed a space to make an
installation that would allow for people
as you know the idea of the sort of
museum is to go down so from
top level all the way to the to the
ground floor the ID here would be to go
down but not within the exhibition
spaces but in fact within the void
itself and that's what we call it the
experiencing the void installation and
is this sort of bouncing net that
spirals down all the way to the to the
ground floor and so this this is of
course not not done as a project but
it's a it's an ID which brings me to a
person that I respect a lot is a scalar
I was myself a scalar for years and I
sort of a like in particular these guys
work I call it work but most people
would call it a destruction which is a
sort of form of Street skating that's
extremely advanced I'm just going to
show a video of what he does and so
obviously you know skating industry is
all about sort of you know destroying or
abusing the streetscape one thing that's
interesting about the way does he is
just like he's also sort of manipulating
the tool itself but he's using which is
a skate board he invented this way of
sliding where he slides on the grip like
this which was you know it's only a
total revolution when you came out at
least four ice skaters and I just
feeling like it's type of intervention
in space is really a sort of thing that
we would like to contribute to the war
work so let's see if we manage these are
some of the project that I would
classify in different ways this is like
two or three projects that I call
program landscapes are infected basis
mostly public spaces that we have
injected with some programs such as this
youth house in Copenhagen it's a sailing
club and a youth house so it's devoted
to you know young kids and what was
interesting about it is that not only
the project provided you know the spaces
and they can
community spaces that were required but
also it provided this kind of somehow
like the topography of spaces that were
not so required but unleash a kind of
attitude towards using the facilities
this is actually a day where we went to
shoot where the kids decided to form to
sort of rival teams because there's two
hills and they were trying to kind of
you know get the heel of the opponent
and so they started like so playing with
these virtual wave guns with hockey
sticks trying to I mean basically doing
what kids do but in this environment
being like a quite exciting setting for
a photo shoot another project that we
accomplished in the early years 2003
here for the harbour bath in Copenhagen
was the idea to actually just provide
you know a space for for outdoor bathing
and and sort of outdoor public use on
the water itself plugging it onto the
existing part so it just came up to be
this sort of very busy place actually
not so busy on this picture but normally
on some days you have like you know you
can't even lay a towel on this on this
park and later on we were asked we
participated in a competition to do a
huge public space on the other side
because the other side the side of the
harbour is completely depraved of
activities hardly anything happening
maybe thanks to some of these by really
ugly and big buildings that are not
doing anything for the public space so
the idea there was to actually create a
sort of extension of the piers this is
the way it looks today which is pretty
deadly and to extend the Pierce onto the
water from again by doing that creating
a sort of series of new connections a
new promenade and then like trying to
kind of place these different locations
these different
squares in a way that would allow for a
722 to be optimized giving a few spaces
for actual water activities so it's not
a swimming pool a search but it is a
canoe and kayaking part and so ending up
with this scheme that where you can see
one one particular aspect is that it
actually Rica next to the harbour bath
unfortunately that's an aspect that we
fighting for still the reconnection to
the harbour bath the reason why i think
is really an important one is because
it's sort of a it may it gives an
understanding of the city as a whole
instead of being like you know the one
side against the other side it's very
much about saying okay if there's stuff
happening on one side we can use it and
drag it over onto the other side so does
the scheme as it should be developed
we're going to start construction in
September sorry January so first month
of the mix here we just get prizes back
from the construction companies and it's
okay so we can we can attack this is a
series of programs within the project
that are added that I'm not you know
purely public spaces such as shops is
the canoe sort of Club and as I
explained this connection back onto the
land of the Ahava bath which brings me
to a sort of similar project in many
ways in Italy in the city of rimini i'm
just showing is a ridiculous picture
because i had to present that project
the day after the dutch and the italian
team had a game and italian lost and
because of my name it felt like a bit of
an issue this map is also like a Dutch
name so i was fearing a lot of sort of
negative responses both from the mayor
side but also from the citizens and now
top of that there was this other
historical moment because i cannot hide
my you know French accent and
once a half French so there is like
other situation and so I basically
showed this picture to these people so
explaining that this was not so much
about you know who I was or where I was
coming from but much more about their
own issues and the city of remedy is an
interesting place because historically
in Europe I was like one of the first
sort of beach party places you know
before we design stuff and now it's sort
of dying out as a as a person place and
it's more becoming as a kind of family
holiday place and the mayor of course
wants to turn into this kind of cultural
hub for high calcium so the site of the
competition is a private private public
partnership competition this thing is
1.6 kilometer long stretch and with our
sole competitor is Jean avail and I'm
still waiting for results the program is
like a series of you know cultural
venues and then a lot of restaurants and
shops and public spaces and the ideas
that we had was to come and look at the
site as what it is which is pretty much
a divided between two cities the one is
you know the historical city of you see
and the other one is the beach city
which is literally a city and that's
what it's kind of exceptional about it
there's so many buildings they actually
have addresses they actually have
numbers you know for these buildings are
of course not real buildings that are
shags where you can you know they get a
drink or change or have restrooms
different things and then the issue is
basically how do how do we deal with the
connection along the sea and across from
that city to the other one so we have
this situation that if you walk along
the sea along their kind of waterfront
you don't see the sea you don't have any
relationship to it because of this other
one story city that kind of stretches
the water from so we decided to do
something that would actually allow from
going you know down and up allow from
the idea of like sort of relating
visually to to the sea but also can
physically to the city behind and then
we made like a bunch of studies for that
which we always do in order to get to
some sort of idea of a you know what
could what could work what could be an
inspiration in this case it was very
literal the bullet marks you know
pattern of a Copacabana is extremely
interesting because it's the perfect and
a contraction of a long and a sort of
transversal axis so we started exploring
this condition and develop it almost
sort of naturally over the whole site in
order to create these two conditions
this is the program breakdown and what's
interesting is that the fabric of it is
very similar but as you splice it and
work with it in a three-dimensional way
you start playing with its edges or like
it'sit's kind of extremes to the point
of having here on the edge a sort of a
hotel of nine stories that you know it's
like a real sort of mount you can climb
it if you if you have the condition for
but it's a it's exactly the same sort of
fabric as the rest of the project so
within that footprint that's very even
there's a lot of conditions that can
occur and these conditions are happening
in a three-dimensional manner where you
have you know restaurants and like sort
of parking spaces and different shops
that are all kind of inserted within the
fabric but at the same time you have a
kind of hundred percent space of public
space so this is the tehran flow first
floor and then if you look at it in the
streetscape it's also
accessible this is the hotel which I
think this is a plan of so it's it is a
nine-story building it's pretty dense
it's actually a rather traditional type
of hotel in the sense that it has you
know a corridor and like room facing the
city in room changing the sea but of
course it's in the section that it sort
of becomes a special place and this is
like a project that we did actually it's
probably the last project I've been
working on for Brazil we were called up
by a group called ebx for standing for I
ki Batista group whose you know Brazil
the richest man who wants to do to
develop a new Convention Center and sort
of a shopping mall in the Gloria
neighborhood of Rio what's interesting
about that neighborhood in particular is
that is overloaded with history and very
heavy historical issues such as you know
World War two is monument or Museum of
Modern Art at the same time it's loaded
with infrastructural conditions such as
the airport and this is exactly where
you know the project start to make sense
and to be interesting is where it meets
you know a need and a sort of a
historical setting what we've been
trying to do is to actually stretch I
mean of course the landscape around is
extremely interesting and almost
something you cannot compete against so
we neither we've tried not to do too
much architecture in that project you
have you know the museum of modern art
which is
very present and very strong piece of
architecture then you have bullet marks
that comes all the way through the
Flamingo Park and it's omnipresent in
that side a big deal that I didn't I
wasn't aware of that you know in Brazil
it's so hard to actually do anything
when you have historical settings
because the whole country is kind of
frozen into its sort of historical
beauties like for instance bullet marks
being present it's almost meaning that
you cannot do any architecture so one
thing that we were very much aware of is
that outside was you know the kind of
center of focus of all these location at
the same time we cannot do too much I
mean we have to sort of like be torn
down this is the marina requirements we
decided to create a new pier which would
become a peer that actually blogs the
wave so that the marina can be fully
used and then within that pier we would
stretch the program so what you have is
basically a pretty mundane sort of not
so interesting a set of programmatic
requirements restaurant shopping
Convention Center and a big exhibition
hall so the idea was to like stretch
that as much as we could over onto the
site create some patios to actually give
in you know landscape qualities to a
program that normally doesn't have any
which is you know the convention hole
and then start manipulating that cross
into letting the whole neighborhood come
in the reason why we did all this and of
course benefiting from some views was
the reason we did this kind of very open
plan very landscape like project was in
order to try to deal with a problem that
there is locally which is of course you
know a violence mm a sort of segregation
so that what's happening currently on
the sides that the whole site is
spending stuff and what we advocating is
total openness what we believe is that
this neighborhood needs to have a
certain return of you know neighbors
taking over their own spaces which is
currently not happening at all so that
the project would actually allow for you
know series of activities to occur and
therefore it's sort of more natural type
of control on the side there is also one
big requirement was that the the
settings were supposed to be or are
supposed to be the 2016 olympics
departure for the sailing competition so
you have like a series of demands that
needed to be dealt with so in the end
the project is ending up as kind of
pretty simple a loop of four strains
iran you know this exhibition hall
please like this and very much I mean
what's sad about yeah this is better
like here you can see that it sort of
links the whole park connections from
bull amount which actually surrounds the
whole bay so unfortunately this project
we recently heard we lost so it's not
going to happen at least not going to
happen like that some local guy get get
the job but we're looking forward to
seeing to see what they came up with
which brings me to a actually a series
of the performative architecture that
also will never perform it's a three
projects that we've been I working on
there are all lost projects but I think
are interesting because first I've never
shown them the recent projects and
except from one of them and secondly I
think it's also like it's interesting to
see that you know within the practice we
we try to achieve something that
sometimes doesn't really get to where it
should be but it's an important aspect
of the project if you take this this is
a beirut so it's a project for the
performing arts house in beirut and it's
a site that's very special because it's
located on one side you have you know a
Skyway or sort of a highway that divides
really two neighborhoods one is the new
BCD be huge central district which is
you know very incredible the kind of
developing a ground and the other one is
this sort of like most of historical
neighborhood that's somewhat left as is
the site was of course regulated very
specifically what we decided is to
actually try to take an abstract first
take on the on the project and do this
kind of 40 by 40 queue full volume and
try to see what we could do with it
there's a series of programs that are
required and of course it's a it's
pretty exciting a condition because it's
all sort of performing and art programs
another thing that was maybe your thing
I was much more interesting about the
whole brief was that they outline a
specificity of the of the Beirut art
scene is that they have a lot of street
art happening our street performances so
what we started looking at is ways to
put the program together in in in a
manner that would allow for some sort of
a perazzi
or some elements of porosity within the
building these kind of various decks of
various terrazas that will allow for
public performances to occur so this is
the sort of volume that we ended up with
that allows for you know an entrance
front and back that would be an open
entrance that would allow for anything
to happen and then a kind of Shiraz deck
that also allows for for public
performances so you have the kind of
conditions of you and then the way you
circulate through the building is
actually abdo so you can get from one to
the other of these sort of open spaces
out door and then you get into the real
sort of official performance spaces that
are in a way symbolically a it's
unfortunate that then they end up being
on the top because of course it's what
we want to show is that the main thing
is the sort of voice but that there's
also some practical issues so this is
you know the way the place should be and
if you look at it I mean it's a building
that's mostly a experience in section
you have these sort of the big holes and
the exhibition spaces and the theatre
here the cinema but then mostly is these
sort of voids that are orchestrating or
organizing the actual solids so that's
the view from the back when you have you
know a stage that's open there this is
the top stage or the top to us that's
the kind of lobby where you know the
interior the sort of a the arrival space
gets sucked into the interior
the place this is just the performance
hall and the plan very simple in a way
very basic I'm going to go through in
detail but in the section again I mean
you get to see the the idea of the
project we have no entrance hall back
entrance hall with happenings and this
little to us and the rest is sort of a
library here offices exhibition space
and auditoriums moving on from there to
a project in a in Taipei that we did as
a sort of the open commutation she's
really tough because can't remember I
mean I think in the Beirut wonders like
it was like six hundred and more soup
metal in this one I don't know how many
but it was also quite a few what was
interesting for us was that the project
was actually suggesting that it would be
it's a pop music center so I mean I
don't know actually much about pop music
but they come a condition that
interested me the most was this divide
in between having an open air scene of
stage in an indoor stage and how we
could sort of place that into a side
there was pretty complex you know one
half was on a one side of a busy road
the other one on the other side and it
was sort of a challenge to deal with
that so what we did is actually trying
to make an urban form or like an urban
project that would deal with these
conditions and then take advantage of it
in order to create a sort of an
unexpected condition of two stages
facing each other across the void so
that void would be the place where
anything could happen and anything could
be from universe Porter them to other
than two big gatherings and so we
basically resolve all the other program
like
all the offices and all the kind of
facilities that were required in order
to get that that sort of a project to
run we use those in order to feel you
know the connections are like the sort
of across the street connections that
were required for the project so you
have this urban escape let's say and
then this sort of a public space
condition of avoid sort of two stages
facing each other across avoid over
viewing the city and connecting on to
the parks and then we had to design also
the full site in terms of parks so we
decided to of course work with this
similar kind of typology of a spaces
just going through quickly so well this
is very burnt but basically these are
like all the sort of boring spaces you
know the basic air the offices and the
different places that are supposed to
create the connections with the public
space on top this is the void across and
the final project
so that's a project that we said lost as
well I mean we get a mention ultimately
doesn't get us very far but but it
allowed us to to think about you know
this issue of sort of urbanity like
urban conditions and public space again
this is a project we did earlier and I'm
just showing it because of its insanity
in a way it's it's a private Danish
developer who came to us and asked us to
design six million square meters which
is kind of completely incomprehensible
set of our conditional scale and he also
said that it had to be a 666 meters high
which was also sort of weird and after a
while he came to and said they was 888
meters and apparently he had like a lot
of discussions you know in the
background because the any said like it
had to be like a hammer Casimir 111
meters out and and on top of all that
you had to be thankfully so you're
starting to get the sort of the idea of
the setting we machines n next to Hong
Kong and it was at this time when you
know shenzhen is sort of booming and
developing as a sort of an extension of
hong kong when we went to the side and
started analyzing it we realized that
the condition was actually across you
know the past 20-30 years I really
depressing there was like no more nature
happening in the in the region went from
this condition of urbanity to this one
in 20 years and this this was actually
happening against you know topography
and everything I mean like sort of a
flattening the land this is Hong Kong so
like as a condition it's very
interesting condition because you have
you know almost like a three-dimensional
urbanism with nature and this was a sort
of version of it in ash and then so what
we started as a kind of question was
could we do a project
you know a new hong kong also an
extension of hong kong this was our site
and when we started looking at i mean
after a lot of tryouts and a lot of
failures trying to do you know an
interesting tower of a thousand 111
meters well and like not really getting
anywhere we just realized that we were
asking us at the wrong question is that
it wasn't about doing a tower it was
actually doing a city that was a real
question so we started looking at this
this condition of overlaying
neighborhoods on to each other and sort
of understanding you know what sort of
components of the neighborhood we could
provide in order to to create that sort
of vertical urbanism and so we came up
with this very simple paper mall that
was actually the sort of start up for
the whole project if you look at the
project in a sort of like in plan and
without the program will just look at
the void the main void is quite funny
that it actually looks like miss van del
Carmen but in fact the project is this
kind of wrong set of programs where you
have on the inside all the commercial
and all the office spaces on the outside
all the residential spaces and then
parks sort of tying these two together
so if you look at in section when it
gets deeper and darker is public
programs such as no cinemas and sports
fields and then when you zoom in you
have you know terrazas towards the
inside and then commercial spaces on the
outside and of course this was you know
a study would say it's a it was
developed to a certain level but not not
fully and it was also kind of stopped at
the moment of her
no crisis when developers started
running away from these kind of
development but it was interesting as a
sort of way of thinking in her even like
contextual issues I mean you know that
in the inner in this sort of the
neighborhood of Shenzhen you know
everything will go in like no time so
it's it's also like a way to to deal
with a move that question may be a
pretty radical way but and so we
presented that project to the shenzhen
Biennale back then 2008 and two hours
before presenting actually opening the
Biennale the this model here disappeared
so I was like you know presented on the
in our space and somebody came around
and picked the the tower just the tower
I mean the base was was left it's just
like because it's made of phones other
phone so it's a 1 kilo or 1.5 kilo is
nothing somebody just like left with it
and so I was joking here to a keygen
mother the curator that you know that
project would start you know replicating
like a Hell in a in the region the
future which of course didn't happen
whether it's sort of I mean he was
actually really sort of this stuff about
the whole
story because this kind of Chinese guilt
I don't know what it was I thought it
was really funny and we also like we get
he made a he redid the whole model for
us and then send it to us but he did it
in perspex 100 kilos now so we can I
mean basically it's it's in off as we
can't move it anywhere it's just
impossible and what brings me to a last
project which is a project the damn sort
of completing now for a ski gem and in
Oslo and I'm going to show it in a sort
of different way that I do normally is
slightly more in depth to to give it the
like the whole history behind it's what
interests me interested me in the first
place to do the competition is again an
open competition this time we succeeded
so it's a little more happy ending what
interested me was this sort of history
of the place that it's sort of for like
a hundred years has been the place where
you know ski jumping as a discipline as
evolved and you can see different
iterations of the ski jump can see for
instance it is like super weird setting
of a of a lake natural lake in the
bottom during the summertime like her
sort of pretty picture this weird animal
that landed into this like natural
setting and then in 82 they made this
version of it so it evolved like 18
times until now and this iteration was
the one we had to deal with it's a sort
of the Schism as as we were given to
deal with it was a place where you know
back in 52 when the olympics were on
they had 120,000 people over there which
is the record so far of attendance and
so we looked at this whole history and
started reflecting on it so we did a
competition and won the competition
everything sounded perfect
and then there's happen some post
competition drama there's been a lot
more than what i'm going to show but you
know there's been a few moments first
thing was that you know somebody
proposed that and this is like of course
and in a scandinavian contact everybody
can say whatever they want and of course
they get heard you know in the main
press should the place be changed like
should all become be moved to another
location and there was like quite a bit
of a discussion regarding that issue
because you could save money you could
like to all sorts of things should you
know how i can be covered I mean be an
indoor space there was also going on for
a while of course you know it was killed
because it was way too over budget one
of the problems of all the column as a
location is that it's very windy so
there's a lot of very dangerous place I
mean it's been like no US open these
days it's kinda impossible to get a game
going but I like her in also it's a
little more dangerous because you know
they do jump and sometimes when burst
mode and then accidents it could happen
so another thing was that then they
decided not to build this keygen even
though it had been sort of decided and
you know the competition was won and I
think that's that comes out of this kind
of political sort of attitude to be
scared of too much public opinions then
at some point some guy came up and said
that warned the International architects
community not to submit projects in in
Norway and in also in particular because
you know they would not be realized and
it's true that or slow has a pretty long
string of international competition not
being
alized some of which or may has
participated and so then after all in
December they actually decided to
rehabilitate the ski jump so meaning
like they would do it but they didn't
really really say how what it turned out
to be is that they wanted to make a
renovation of the ski jump and then we
had to which I'll explain to study what
that meant then the person that was
responsible for that get kicked out
because she cannot hit she was hiding
some budget problems that were occurring
with the with the competition and the
reality of the budget this project
started in 2005 with as a kind of
political decision to be a 15 million
Norwegian corner project when in 2007 we
took out the competition it was a 500
million corner budget and we ended up
building it for 800 million so you could
see that there's like a pretty little
sort of extensive gap of knowledge in
terms of like budget calculation and she
is partially responsible of that so in
this mess we started the petition
because we could see that things were
like so sketchy that we had to intervene
so we actually made a competition on the
online but you could support you know
our project and it recorded like a 2,000
words which I think was enough to you
know start a certain this discussion
among the municipality then came up this
issue that you know that we were not
exactly a professional in ski jumping
and there is that's so true because if
you know anything about Denmark and
Belgium is like the two most flat
countries in the world to get away with
the Netherlands so if you look at the
history of Norway with you know all
these like and this was also learning
from me you know
all these great names historical and
contemporary create ski jumpers and you
take Denmark and it's got like you know
basically one skier that's okay and it's
a it's an alpine skier and and like
Belgium has known so the question was
like this sort of you know looking at
the AHA's achievements and instead of
you know the pretty important
achievement when it comes to ski jumping
and this kind of wondering you know what
has actually a sort of a lot of that
condition it just completely like taking
it as a joke but like also like sort of
as a way to sort of get back to the
issue of you know the criticism that we
were we were under this attack of you
know whether we would be able to do it
or not so the first thing was you know
being a region and whatever that meant
you know wearing some crazy hats but
basically meant like being like having a
local office which is what we did so we
open up an office in nostril and then
sort of discussing this issue of the
icon of the country of a nation and sort
of looking at what that could mean in
terms of in terms of a project and in
fact at that point trying to re-explain
you know what our project was about so
we just sort of went in and explain you
know the basic cell project over and
over in order to kind of gain back this
sort of agreement that we already get
officially from the competition but in
this case from the citizens and the
basic idea was to say okay there's an
ideal slope and this is something that
we have as a given and there's issues of
wind protection so we making you know
the wind protection condition then we
sort of extending that and by offsetting
that considering you know maybe a
simplification of the shape by doing so
we also decide to move
all the all the land program the program
that's supposed to support the project
into the hill so that it becomes a sort
of a slightly more simple shape that
then is being reconnected by an elevator
so that all programs are along one
string then the kind of cherry on top
was to say instead of the making a
project that is an icon only it's
actually a project that allows for
rethinking you know the ID of the icon
and actually stating that the icon is in
fact or slow because what's interesting
about this location if there is the best
place to view Oslo so this is the Oslo
fuel and this is how you could sort of
imagine you know experiencing that place
outside you know whether it rains or
snows or whatever you could actually see
the city in most kind of amazing
condition so these are views from the
competition then later on we worked on
the project developing you know the
different sort of like little aspects of
that and I go through some of them this
is the project that we ended up getting
an agreement on you see it's pretty
faithful to the original project but I
go to some aspects of deaths that are
sometimes great sometimes really painful
we were first required to study a
rehabilitation which meant that we add
actually to renovate potentially the
structure so instead of doing a whole
new gem we also were asked to study this
and and by study I mean like go all the
way through and this is like basically
wrapping the existing ski gym with a
steel structure just in order to extend
it for a few meters which was totally
absurd and this was the other study that
we had to make which is our
from the competition finally in April we
are given you know the news that we
going to be hired for the job that we
already won you know months before but
then they still don't know what to do
and they don't know what level of ASCII
gem they're going to be doing because
there's all these different sort of
steps in ski jumping you know from the
k18 the k15 115 was like the existing
one so we still don't know in the end
they kind of settle for like a hundred
and twenty and then we start studying it
there's a lot of like sort of very
demanding little aspects that I'm not
going to go through but in the end we
end up agreeing on this setup in this
way of explaining the project and
different sub condition different sub
projects that we had to deal with with
different levels of importance so you
have of course the interim like the
actual jump and the landing it's a very
important aspect of the project because
the lending is in fact really expensive
to make considering that you have to dig
into the rocks of the scale of the
landscape and little things such as this
commentator and and judges boxes very
demanding as well because every judge
has to see the germ from the very top to
the very end than the arena the media
boxes where basically all the TV and
john melissa and then all these
different conditions if you look on the
other side one that I will sort of point
that is this weird combo of the Kings
lounge so it's like where the royal
family hangs out and then the shop
beautiful package and so if you take
that that location as the the kind of
royal family lounge with their you know
guest of honor and so it of course has
to be sort of a grand spot but at the
same time you know when we went through
the first revision of the the project
after they cannot build it you know
according to drawings but totally not
according to details we heard like a
poll by you know the level of interest
that the Norwegians have towards their
royal family is it looked like a like a
shantytown some sold so so this is
changing now the structure of the jump
is of course the main thing and the way
it's built is it's a steel structure
it's in fact I wouldn't say that
interesting I mean not that sort of
advanced you know it's a lot of Steel I
mean a thousand tons of steel it's been
in eight pieces so it's it's sort of a
being billion Owen chunks and we had to
set up a sort of workshop or like I can
I assembly shop at the back of the jump
in order to do to make this possible so
all the older portions in the section
that you see were assembled fully as you
see them here in this location and in
order to compose the full of structure
one thing I was though quite a battle to
get through is the fact that we had to
study you know the deformations in the
wind of the John not so much because we
were fearing that it was going to break
but in fact because it's it's a matter
of comfort and of just simple you know
use of the the hill as a job so so we
consider at some point making putting
any huge weight on the top in order to
kind of stabilize the thing and we have
the possibility to still do so if it's
necessary but we need to kind of
experiment the jump a little bit before
so this is in tune with the facade the
fsr is you know something that needs to
kenai
act as a buffer towards the winds
because of course it takes a lot of wins
so the point is that it has to be
perforated and up to a fifty percent
over here and in between 35 and 50
percent for the jam itself so we went
through a series of different options
like for instance this this is what we
did at the mountain again a perforated
steel plate of this one which was really
exciting as a chi chainmail but also
extremely expensive and in fact in order
to make it at all we had to like press
the button of you know like start
production immediately as we had won the
competition in order for it to be even
produced on time because all these rings
are just being welded you know together
one by one so it's a totally insane as a
production it looks beautiful then we
looked at the stretch metal like the new
museum facade which doesn't like
surprisingly doesn't work for for when
buffer because it's there's too much
imprecision and sort of mistakes into
the splicing of the steel that actually
makes creates more turbulence is of
divert more when then you would want to
out of it so in the end we get this one
that was the best resolve in the wind
tunnels it's very straightforward sort
of a mesh that stretches a one way and
allows for one thing that is extremely
practical and became like the concept of
the whole facade which is that you can
just stretch it from one side all the
way through down and then hook it back
up one piece and that became interesting
in the idea of actually creating this
sort of a feeling of you know this kind
of stretch a piece that you bend so that
if you cannot zoom on it it's actually
like literally being bent
a sort of almost as a as a fabric this
is just pictures during construction
it's pretty tough to a built in no way
okay gets Revere great really cold and
snowy so this is the making so finally
in October we started construction and
this is just as a kind of a kind of
symbol you know we had we decapitated
the existing ski job so I took the head
off and it's actually still lying on
side next door I don't know what they
got to do with it he's just going to
stand there and rot so this was the
first in a way the first condition of
construction and the first failure is
that you can see that this existing
building around which we building is is
a sort of a remain of the OL jam and
it's something I'm still trying to get
rid of but I don't think I'm managing
it's what's what we call the cubic it's
an existing administration building that
is somehow being excuse to call this
renovation and not a new build on a
political level so is this big question
of whether we have the cool big are we
actually deal with it and try to take it
away or slice it so that there is a
visual connection between the two sides
of the ski jump which is has been the
intention for the from the competition
all along so basically the idea is that
you have the lobby entrance here and
then you could go down you know into the
arena from this staircase existing
building and
have this so interaction of the
different programs but currently it's
working like this and not like this as
we're trying to get it hard to see
anything so this is the underside of the
the jump and this is when we started
like you know feeling how the jump would
be and the sort of various steps of
building the structure I'm just trying
to go through this was like a midterm of
his visits where we brought the whole
office to see the jump like I said it's
a really tough place to build like a
it's foggy almost like half of the time
and then number on the form of 24 we
raised up the last piece the 8 section
of the drum which is pretty dramatic
experience especially when you get
closer and closer and these dudes were
just smoking cigarettes and like holding
and other thing
I really a and then that's when you know
you're working in a sort of the Viking
I'll and so it took it took a while to
get it in place because of the wind and
that last piece was heavier than most of
the other one you can see that the the
connection was made then we kept the
crane holding it for quite a while while
it was being like really sort of
gradually to test that you know the
cantilever was working i love this is
the moment of lack of trust in in
whatever you know engineering has been a
sort of deployed and so at some point
some guy started coming into the hill
like of course it was far from being
ready but you know it's too tempting so
locally it's such a big you know like
people like the entire neighborhood of
people living just next to the ski time
and they're all like total fanatic
skiers so of course at some point you
know some kid get drunk and they're like
okay let's let's do it now so that was
the first the first moment then a
construction went on until it was sort
of getting close to completion this is
when we started doing so basically like
all this inside stuff is you know just
backbone for placing all the
installations because there's a lot of
insertion going into the structure and
then the project was more or less say it
done in its basic form I mean you can
see that it's still not done over here
but it's all is done with the facade and
then some guys came over and base jump
did and
it's like the sort of ivory only really
bad pictures but it was pretty intense
because of course they had first I had
to burst into the place and then they
had to like climb up the whole thing
sort of i don't think there was even
like I stare at the time and so they
just had to get up and then they base
jumped the sky intense and then another
little issue that happened is that
politically there was a vote to to have
a skier called imitates sanken a woman
skier to be the first jumper to jerm the
hill and that was the sort of like you
know first time a woman would actually
inaugurate you know Olympic ski jump and
then this idiot here is the beyond
Harmon is like the ultimate the sort of
star of ski jumping in a no way yeah
organized together with his friends from
the Ski Association to like poop the
whole political decision and the night
before to George you know illegally on
the hill to sir and apparently later on
he started crying about it on TV was
really sorry but you know she she was
supposed to be the one to sort of do the
first room too bad she didn't so these
are the pictures of what happened right
after which is the the basically the
test championship we had a soft opening
to test the place and that's not in
order to
do a reopening but it was more because
there's a lot of logistics to be dealt
with on site that we had to try out you
know a lot of gymnasts are coming in
like two thousand journalists need to
report from the World Championship so we
had to test it one time first so this
was one of the first jobs during the
championship and just some views of the
place as it is today so we have we're
almost you know finishing the place now
is our views we took during the
championship I love this one where the
whole city is kind of grown in the
clouds and we also did a you know in
order to be able to way with an iphone
app with some some guys in Norway which
unfortunately we didn't manage to to get
the sort of percentage on so they just
like selling like maniacs and we don't
not getting anything and then I'm just
going to end with this image of the the
jumping is what I was too old ones is
that it looked like this fantastic long
chair for God and then then I sort of
tried to find a you know to google that
and find something but it couldn't I
found this one which I thought was
pretty a pretty well placed
I'm just call down it's not because I
want to leave
you
well i mean i think we always trying to
do the full package I mean it's not a
there's a lot of aspects to it but the
main one is of course that it's the only
way we have to to actually explore you
know architecture because when like the
competition level is like maybe ten
percent of what you can explore and then
things such as I mean even though that
the building looks pretty faithful to
you know the competition moment it still
is still like a million things that
happened afterwards that were like you
know improvements and sort of a new new
ideas that came and this is what makes
you know the profession really exciting
obviously but in countries that are you
know much further away like so doing
some work in Mexico or like in Asia it's
harder to first to convince yourself to
do it and then in order to convince your
client to go for it all you have to
again you know open I think if we had
really fought for it we could have
avoided to set up in our local office
for the ski jump because we were only an
hour away I think it's a lot harder when
you like you know having to travel 12
hours and so I think we we would
probably be more keen on either opening
offices or sort of working with someone
locally if it was like further away
project but I haven't really have done
collaborations with offices in China
where they've been doing the detailing
and we've been redlining it and we still
waiting for
the canner drawing to redline it's like
it's really sort of something to
remember in the energy much more I mean
depending on the project some project
are sort of sufficiently standard that
you can do it interestingly enough I
just all launch or like so open a
building in Norway as well in stavanger
for a hotel which did you go or did you
not go in ngozi but you were wrong right
and I'm actually kind of happy you
didn't go through it because there you
know we didn't do the full package we
didn't draw the details of it we had a
local office do it and yeah like I'm not
sure that the you know I would want you
to see it actually I mean there's a lot
of aspects where we didn't have to we
didn't get the chance to battle I mean
we didn't get simply the occasion they
can die capacity to to be involving
decisions and I think that's there's a
big learning actually it's something
that we need to avoid all we need to be
better at sort of selling of those
collaboration in a really
the way that we know who we deal with
and we know what all arise
hello my name is abdallah I just want to
thank you very much for your
presentation there was some very
interesting ideas in there the thing
that I kind of jumped out at me from it
was looking at here at some of the
project that you presented and maybe
it's not something the office in general
but there's a certain scale about your
project I mean the ski-jump has a bit of
a scale on its own that you cannot
really play around with too much but I
was looking at the other one namely the
China one with the tower and the two
theater project where it seemed to be
pretty massive compared to its context
and almost the out of scale compared to
what it is where it's located I'm
wondering that ever came up in
conversation or like public or against
it saying that's too big or if that ever
comes in conversation during the design
process where the scale becomes an issue
or it may be too big or kind of out of
place in that sense and if you can
comment on that I did I think the
Chinese one is it's definitely to be but
you know that was part of the
requirement I don't think you know the
two other ones that being a pretty I
mean they're basically smaller than the
neighbors so I don't think they're kind
of fit in the to be category but I think
just maybe generally the issue of a I'm
fighting a building permit right now in
Brussels for the exact same reason that
I'm being told that the building is too
big it's like two storeys above you know
the neighbors but whatever and thing in
New York I should show you this amazing
picture I found like I just took
yesterday next to my hotel there's this
building that's like this kind of Row
housing kind of thing on eighth avenue
and there's you know three-story
buildings and then there's one insert
like an
in film and it's 40 stories I mean
there's a lot of insane ones in video
but that won't really be your 40 stories
tall and I don't I mean I think the like
contextual issues are to be dealt with
in different terms that you know where
there is too big or too small i mean if
you take the shenzhen project is too big
for where it is now but by the time it's
done the now is gone and the whole
neighborhood has changed completely and
this is I mean if you go to Shenzhen
today is the case all these neighbors
have transformed completely from this
sort of factory landscape do you know
like a much more upgraded type of
programs so yeah I mean it's I mean too
big or too small I don't know it's
something to take care to take with a
little more criticism effing of course
you know a thousand meter tall building
is maybe too big anywhere or is it I
mean it's just really
I don't think the other buildings are
too big in any way like they're just
feels like they fit right in you don't
take too big as a compliment as a
compliment yeah no I don't care yeah but
I mean I'm a happy that it stands out
but not necessarily because it's too big
I mean a happy that it's sort of deals
with complex contextual issues in a way
that is not maybe about whether it's too
big or too small or whether it get you
know the right ornament as the negress
does maybe because it sort of activates
its location in a kind of way that that
makes it stand out on its it relate you
know differently
I was wondering how you keep your
creative process so radical on a
consistent basis how do you be radical
consistently because all of your
buildings have a different look and so
how do you avoid falling into a comfort
zone or something that a pattern that
you repeat over and over but come up
with something different every time I am
too young to have that problem I'm too
young to have that problem of whether
you know it I don't know like I mean one
thing is that you know that the the
process of doing a project is very open
in the office and it's not at all we
don't have this kind of insane
systematic like we have some system in
case we in desperation mode and then we
have like more like a sort of open it
for exploration sometimes even you know
intuition based sort of exploration that
allows for for instance for anyone in
the office to cover up with an idea
which allows for you know diversity all
sort of you know different sort of
results I think maybe my job is sort of
to explore this sort of threat the
comment thread within the projects also
try to kind of find out what is what
could be you know dialogue in between
the different typologies of buildings
we're doing all the different scales non
buildings which is part of the things
that way I was trying to kind of explain
today but the but I'm definitely not
interested in sort of you know issues of
aesthetic so like that things should be
one style or another style is so much
what we
discussing in the office
the
you energized by that of course I mean
you know it's like I think the but I
think it's even for people that haven't
been there
sort of you know finding a sort of it's
not really a method but it's like a way
of exploring I get this this kind of
idea of you know abundance and sort of
insane amount of the of tryouts which is
definitely a way to open up your eyes
but then it's a matter of afterwards of
deciding also and I think we definitely
deciding differently than you know REM
has maybe a shoulders in the past but we
also told you so you know needed that
moment of opening our eyes just like
students do now is there the student
management is that work and school yeah
and the fact that it was I mean you've
given a lot of responsibilities actually
I at least back then I don't know how k
office works today and it was only one
office by Jensen but that was really
interesting that you would have a lot on
your shoulders